>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Marie Arana: English
words are like prisms.
Empty. Nothing inside.
And still they make rainbows.
So says a character in "Already
Dead," a novel by the late,
great American writer Denis Johnson.
Johnson's stories, as legions of
his fans know, are also prisms.
They are hard, merciless, flinty.
And yet they, too, make rainbows.
He has been called a
writer's writer's writer and,
for all the enigma of those three
words, they hold a simple truth.
Those who bring language
to life recognize Johnson's gifts
instantly Louise Erdrich calls his
work "profound" and "transcendent."
Jonathan Franzen finds
"his sentences miracles
of transparency and tone."
Philip Roth calls him
"daring,"terrifying,"
and an emissary for
"tortured," "broken souls."
Marilynne Robinson marvels that
a writer's personal passions
and energies can be so
inextricably wedded to his prose.
All agree.
Denis Johnson has managed to give
us "minimalist," yet distinctly
"ecstatic and hallucinatory"
rainbow prose.
He is an American original.
He was born in 1949 in Munich,
Germany, and raised in Tokyo
and Manila, the child
of Americans diplomats.
As a teenager, moving back
to Washington D.C. during
the tumultuous '60s,
he came to know the country and the
restless characters he would capture
so vividly in his fiction.
He graduated in English literature
from the University of Iowa
and earned an MFA from the
Iowa Writers' Workshop,
where he returned as a teacher.
He has also taught at
Texas State University
and the University
of Texas at Austin.
In the course of his fevered
career, he published novels,
short stories, journalism,
and poetry.
Among his best known works are
those about the flotsam and jetsam
of American life: The
Laughing Monsters, Nobody Move,
Tree of Smoke, Already Dead, Jesus'
Son, Resuscitation of a Hanged Man,
The Stars at Noon,
Fiskadoro, Angels.
He has received numerous
awards for these,
including a National Book Award,
a Lannan Fellowship in Fiction,
a Whiting Writer's
Award, and in 2008,
he was named a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize.
Throughout, he has
chronicled an America
that has gone unobserved,
unrecorded.
Here are our drug addicts, our
war veterans, our disaffected,
our used up and left behind.
And yet the most affecting
and rewarding aspect
of Denis Johnson's fiction
is that, in work after work,
he has proved that beauty often
lurks in unexpected places,
that strength can be
found in failure,
that the human spirit is a
fragile but resilient vessel.
His is a very American story.
He once described his works as
"pressure cookers of language,"
his characters as those who
inhabit life's perilous edge.
As time wore on, he found that
he himself was all too vulnerable
to these human frailties.
When the Librarian of Congress Carla
Hayden offered Denis Johnson The
Library of Congress Prize for
American Fiction in March of 2017,
he wrote in an e-mail message,
"My head is spinning
from such great news."
Two months later, tragically,
he was dead.
The Library is very proud
to honor, posthumously,
this extraordinary human being
and writer, whose contributions
to the American canon have
been lasting and invaluable.
As the Librarian wrote when the
prize was announced in June, 2017:
"Denis Johnson was a
writer for our times.
In prose that fused grace with
grit, he spun tale after tale
about our walking wounded,
the demons that haunt,
the salvation we seek.
We emerge from his imagined
world with profound empathy,
a different perspective-a
little changed.
We are very proud to count Denis
Johnson among the distinguished
winners of the Library of Congress
Prize for American Fiction.
>> This is been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.